the Umbrella Academy was a breakout set
for Netflix pulling in viewers and
generating buzz on its debut in early
2019 it's no surprise that the show is
returning for a second season especially
considering the cliffhanger that closed
the first but what can we expect when
the Academy comes back right now there's
no official release date for the second
season of the Umbrella Academy but we do
know one is coming when can we expect it
well we have a theory in January 2018
comic creators Gerard Way and Gabriel
Barr shared a picture from the first day
of production the show itself premiered
just over a year later in February 2019
- got underway in June 2019 if we take
the first season as a model that means
we can hopefully expect season two
somewhere in the second half of 2020
obviously it's not a perfect estimate
we'll have an update when we get an
official word but fans can probably
pencil in late 2020 until further notice
all of Reginald Hargreaves has children
we'll be back for the second season
played by the same actors the official
Twitter accounts for the Umbrella
Academy shared a video on June 15 2019
showing the first script reading for the
second season we knew that the entire
principal cast was returning for the
second season of Umbrella Academy but
we've been in the dark as to what
newbies might be coming aboard no longer
in September Netflix announced the three
new cast members that we will see in the
show's second season Yousef Gatewood
Marin Island and Rito aya Gatewood was
recently seen as famine one of the four
horsemen and Amazon Prime's Good Omens
adaptation in Umbrella Academy he will
play Raymond who Netflix ascribes as a
charismatic born leader if you're a
member famine smooth-talking from Good
Omens that sounds perfectly suited for
Gatewood I learned to a place Cissy has
dozens of credits to her name but sneaky
pete is one of the most likely to ring
some bells oh yeah we'll play Lila
described in a press release as a
chameleon who can be as brilliant or
insane as a situation requires she has
appeared in several BBC shows as well as
the AMC series humans interestingly none
of these characters have appeared in the
Umbrella Academy comics at least not yet
even with these announcements we're
still in the dark about where season two
story is headed we also don't know which
other major players from the first
season might be back time-traveling
assassins Char Char and hazel has
significant roles in the first season as
did Reginald Hargreaves Agnes and the
handler we could very well see some of
them again but due to the events of the
finale none of these characters will be
absolutely essential in carrying the
second seasons plot forward don't follow
this madness time to stir over the end
of the umbrella Academy's first season
saw most of us siblings joining together
to try to stop their sister Vanya in a
full badass white violin persona from
bringing about the apocalypse they did
not succeed with their efforts to stop
Vanya inadvertently sending a wave of
energy towards the moon pieces of the
moon began to rain down destroying the
world just as the siblings jumped back
in
this ending differs a bit from the first
volume of the comic but it followed the
same basic path it seems likely that
season two will at least draw
inspiration from the second volume of
the comic dulles this story deals with
the Academy trying to assassinate JFK in
order to prevent the apocalypse somehow
considering they were unable to stop the
world from ending at the end of the
first season traveling back in time and
giving it another go seems like a fairly
solid plan however the story going
forward may deviate from the comics the
first episode of the second season is
titled right back where we started so
while it seems a given that the siblings
are going back to the past when it comes
to where exactly we'll have to wait and
see the umbrella Academy's first season
was a huge hit for Netflix as long as it
keeps people tuned to the streaming
platform Netflix will probably find a
way to keep financing the show and
there's a lot of comic material to keep
them going in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter Gerard Way and
showrunner Steve Blackman
talked about the plans story Way said
that he has eight volumes of comic
stories planned and that black man has
an outline of major plot points however
the first season of the show two
elements from both the first and second
volumes so a 1 volume equals one season
formula doesn't necessarily work here
the publication schedule of the Umbrella
Academy comics has been a bit all over
the place
the first issue was released in 2007
with the first two volumes apocalypse
suites and Dallas collected in their
entirety by the end of 2008 the third
and to date final collected Umbrella
Academy story is Hotel oblivion despite
US announcement immediately after the
conclusion of Dallas Hotel oblivion
didn't begin publication until 2018 so
why the long delay our world is changing
has changed comic creator gerard way is
awesome a musician best known for his
work with My Chemical Romance though the
band broke up in 2013 he has remained
busy with solo work and he's also
written numerous other comic book
projects but that doesn't mean he's
abandoned the Umbrella Academy story
Wade told The Hollywood Reporter that he
is planning on eight volumes and he
hopes that the comics can stay ahead of
the show speaking to Radio Times Way
said that the overall goal is basically
to not fall into the trap that hit Game
of Thrones as he puts it the goal for us
stay ahead of the show and since we're
on Series three of the comics we are now
ahead of the show while we wait for a
second season of the show we can likely
expect to start hearing news about the
fourth volume of the books according to
way the idea of the comic is to go right
from series three take a three to four
month break then go right into series
four there a story there and us all
planned out obviously the most logical
prediction about where the umbrella
Academy's second season is headed would
be the JFK assassination however there
are plenty of other mysteries from the
pages of the books at the show could
turn to the show touched on it with a
little more backstory about Sir Reginald
would be nice especially considering
that in the comics
we're told that he's an alien almost
immediately the last episode of the
first season gave some hints towards
this but never really addressed it along
those lines that revelation would also
raise another obvious question what
about all the other mystery children
there are supposedly 42 of them and
Reginald enlisted seven to begin his
Academy season two could certainly catch
up with some of those other kids the
other looming possibility is the hotel
of Libyan and specifically the character
of John Perseus a new season will need a
good villain and Perseus seems like a
likely candidate especially if he works
more in the background of the second
season before becoming an even bigger
threat in season 3 the Umbrella Academy
has dealt with other villains but
Perseus seems like the best bet for
television so while the comics can give
us hints about where the story of the
show is going the only way we'll know
for sure what happens is to wait and
watch season 2 unfold check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
Netflix shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel under the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
you
[Applause]